form shown on the screen which critically is a product State we have our original uncorrupted encoding as the
right- hand tensor factor which is what is most important here and on the left we have a density Matrix s that
describes a random error syndrome but there's no longer any correlation with the system that we care about which is
the one on the right because the errors have been corrected at this point we can throw the syndrome cubits away or reset them in
case we want to use them again and that's actually pretty important because this is how the randomness or entropy
generated by errors is removed from the system and that's how the discretization of Errors works at least for unitary
errors in essence by measuring the syndrome we effectively project the error onto an error that's described by
a poly Matrix at first glance it may seem too good to be true that we can correct for arbitrary unitary errors
like this even errors that are tiny and hardly noticeable on their own but what's important to realize here
is that this is a un error on a single Cubit and by the design of the code a single Cubit operation cannot change the
state of The Logical Cubit that's being encoded all it can possibly do is to move the state out of the space of valid
encodings but then the corrections bring it right back to where it was finally let's consider what happens
when an arbitrary not necessarily unitary error occurs the setup is the same as before
we've encoded one cubit into 9 using the short code and some arbitrary error represented by a cubit Channel thi
occurs on one of the cubits as we'll see everything is going to work out in pretty much the same way
as it did for unitary errors and the first step toward verifying this is to consider a cross representation of our
error what we can do now is to follow exactly the same reasoning as for unitary errors except that we apply that
reasoning to the Cross matrices rather than to a single unitary Matrix representing an error
in particular each cruss Matrix can be expressed as a linear combination of poly matrices and this allows us to
express the action of this error fi on whatever cubic K it happens to in the form that's shown here on the
screen all we're really doing here is to expand out the cross matrices as linear combinations of poly
matrices if we then compute and measure the error syndrome and correct for any errors that are revealed we'll obtain a
similar sort of state to what we had in the case of a unitary error I won't go through the details it's all quite similar to the unitary
case and also a little bit Messier to write down but conceptually speaking it's pretty
straightforward I should mention that this all generalizes to other Quantum error correcting codes including codes that can correct for errors on multiple
cubits in such a case errors on multiple cubits can be expressed as linear combinations of tensor products of poly
matrices and corresponding ly the different possible syndromes will describe Corrections that are performed on multiple cubits rather than just one
cubit but the underlying idea is exactly the same again by measuring the syndrome
we effectively project or collapse errors into a discrete set of possibilities represented by tensor
products of poly metrices and by correcting those errors meaning the poly errors we can recover the original
encoded State meanwhile whatever Randomness is generated in the process is moved into the syndrome cubits which we can then
discard or reset which is crucial because that's how the entropy generated by errors and syndrome measurements is
removed from the system and that is the end of the lesson in which we've taken a first look at
Quantum error correction including the 9 Cubit Shore code and the discretization of Errors I hope you will join me for the
next lesson in which we'll discuss the stabilizer formalism which provides us with a powerful tool for describing and
analyzing a large and interesting class of quantum error cting codes including ones that are promising candidates for
real quantum computers goodbye until then